Các quy định tại khoản bẩy điều 3.5 lật khoản lý thuê số 3.5 hành hành hành hủ trăm 14,000
quy hát 14 và điều bẩy thông tư tà mấy sáo hành hủ trăm 2.5 tư TTVTC.
Tương ngày 1,5 hành hủ trăm 2.5, số định dành cá nhân sẽ được sự dụng thay cho mắt số thuê của hổ gia đình.
Hổ kinh dành, cá nhân kinh dành, cá nhân.
số định dành cá nhân thay cho mắt số thuê của người nộp thế bà ngồm.
Cá nhân có thu nhập thuộc dễn chữ thuê thu nhập cá nhân.
Cá nhân là người phụ thuộc theo quy định của pháp lật tư tư nhập cá nhân.
Người đại dịnh hổ gia đình, đại dịnh hủ kinh dành, cá nhân kinh dành.
Tổ chức, hổ gia đình và cá nhân khác còn nghĩa vụ với người xách nhận nữa.
Bây giờ thực hiện mắt số thuê xa mắt số định dành cá nhân từ ngày 1,5 bẩy nắm hành hủ trăm 2.5 sế được trình 2 với các trường hợp.
Một, chương hợp người nộp thế thông tinh khớp đúng.
2, chương hợp người nộp thế thông tinh khẩp đúng.
Bà, chương hợp cá nhân được cấp nhiều hợp 1 mắt số thuê.